pro-choice always made sense to me  because I don't like people telling me  what to do and I always just like it's  your body who the [ __ ] am I to tell you  what to do with your body so that always  made sense all right however  I still think you're killing a baby  see  that's where it gets weird it's not a  baby yet that's what they say which may  or may not be true I don't know I'm not  a doctor but I'll tell you my gut tells  me that doesn't make sense  it's not a baby yet that would be like  if I was making a cake and I poured some  batter in a pan and I put it in the oven  and then five minutes later you came by  and you grabbed the pen you threw it  across the floor  now what the [ __ ] you just ruined my  birthday cake and then you were like  well that wasn't a cake yet  it's like well it would have been  you didn't do it you just did there  would have been a cake in 50 minutes  something happened in that tank you cake  murder inside of a [ __ ]